so und jetzt fragen wir uns mal wieder
gibt es außerirdische schauen sie mal
auf diese bilder hier das foto dass wir
ihn jetzt zeigen dass es beziehungsweise
die aufnahmen die sind 75 jahre alt und
was glauben sie sind das etwa und
quatsche vorteile aufgenommen wurde das
ganze im bundesstaat new mexico ja noch
immer gibt es keine antwort
[Musik]
75 jahre galaktischer heim
75 jahre agent im anflug
75 jahre ufo absturz in roswell
diese szenen schrieben geschichte die
alien autopsie aus dem jahr 1947 in 17
minütigen schwarz weiß streifen sie
ihren zwei wissenschaftler ein
unbekanntes wesen mit wasserkopf und
riesen augen erst 1995 48 jahre nach
veröffentlichung wird der film als
fälschung enttarnt
ganz anders das geheimnis um den ufo
absturz von roswell noch immer weiß
keiner was genau passierte am 8 juli
1947 in der us kleinstadt in new mexico
was sind das für wrackteile fliegende
untertasse oder wetterballon einer war
sich da ganz sicher major jesse marcel
senior damals geheimdienstoffizier bei
der us-luftwaffe bild spricht mit seinem
enkel
1947 wurde mein großvater von seiner
basis beauftragt sich einen ort
anzusehen mit ungewöhnlichen objekten
irgendeine absturzstelle er warf einen
blick auf die wrackteile und stellte
fest dass er so etwas noch nie gesehen
hat der geheimdienst offizier schnappt
sich einen karton sammelt einige teile
ein pferd damit nach hause er verteilt
sie in der küche und untersucht die
objekte gemeinsam mit seiner frau und
dem damals zehnjährigen sohn jesse
junior
[Musik]
was die teile außergewöhnlich machte sie
waren sehr widerstandsfähig und enorm
leicht eine der metallstreben lieber
circa 1 meter 20 lang brachte mein opa
zum waschbecken er stellte fest dass die
symbole darauf erscheinen wenn er die
strebe etwas ins licht gibt beim blick
von oben sommer nichts und mein
großvater sagte es könnte sein dass wir
hier gerade auf ein stück alien sprache
die vermeintlichen sprache gelangt nicht
an die öffentlichkeit die regierung und
das militär vertuschen dem vorfall
zeitzeugen wie jazz oper werden als
spinner abgestempelt es ist die zeit des
kalten krieges geheimnisse bleiben
geheim erst vor wenigen monaten führt
das pentagon öffentlich eine ufo debatte
ich glaube durch die öffentliche debatte
des pentagons und anderer
regierungsbehörden hat der rest der welt
seine ufer wahrnehmung verändert das
zeigt dass mein grossvater eben kein
verrückter war der sich eine irre
geschichte über ein gecrashter
ausgedacht hat selbst regierungsbehörden
stellen klar dass es da draußen dinge
gibt die wir nicht verstehen
ihrer meinung nach denken sie wirklich
dass das passiert ist der absturz eines
alien raumschiff
ich bin überzeugt dass es der absturz
eines ufos war einer fliegenden
untertasse bis zu ihrem tod sind weder
mein großvater noch mein vater je von
ihrer geschichte abgewichen wieso sollte
man seine kinder und enkelkinder ein
leben lang
und so lebt sie weiter die legende vom
ufer absturz in roswell
[Musik]